[Music]
you're the chief advisor to an eccentric
king who needs to declare his successor
he wants his heir to be good at
arithmetic
lucky and above all else honest
so he's devised a competition to test
his children
and ordered you to choose the winner
each potential heir will be given the
same two six-sided dice
the red die has the numbers 2 7 7
12 12 and 17. the blue one
has 3 8 8 13 13
and 18. the dice are fair so each side
is
equally likely to come up each
contestant will be sent into a royal
rolling room
where they'll roll both dice 20 times
a contestant's score starts at zero and
each turn they should add the total of
the two numbers rolled to their score
after 20 turns they should report their
final score
the rooms are secure and no one observes
the roles
that means a contestant could add
incorrectly
or worse be dishonest and make up a
score they didn't achieve
this is where you come in the king has
instructed you
that if you're at least 90 percent sure
a contestant
misadded or cheated you should
disqualify them
the highest scoring player who remains
will be the new
heir to the throne after you explain the
rules
the children run to their rooms when
they return
alexa announces her score is 385.
bertram says 840. cassandra reports
700 and draco declares 423
the future of the kingdom is in your
hands whom do you proclaim to be the
worthiest
successor
upon inspection most of these scores are
concerning
let's start with the highest bertram
scored 840.
that's impressive but is it even
possible the highest numbers on the two
dice
are 17 and 18. 17
plus 18 is 35 so in 20 rolls
the greatest possible total is 20 times
or 700. even if bertram
rolled all the highest numbers he
couldn't have scored 840
so he's disqualified cassandra the next
highest roller reported
700 that's theoretically possible
but how hard is it to be that lucky
in order to get 700 cassandra would have
to roll the highest number out of 6
on 40 separate occasions the probability
of this
is 1 over 6 to the 40th power
or 1 in about 13 million
that's 13 followed by 30 zeros
to put that in perspective there are
about 7.5 billion people in the world
and 7.5 billion squared is a lot less
than 13
non-million rolling the highest number
all 40 times is much less likely
than if you picked a completely random
person
on earth and it turned out to be actor
paul rudd
and then you randomly picked again and
got paul rudd
again you can't be 100
sure that cassandra's score didn't
happen by chance
but you can certainly be 90 percent sure
so she should be disqualified
next up is draco with 423
this score isn't high enough to be
suspicious
but it's impossible for a different
reason pick a number from each die and
add them up
no matter which combination you choose
the result
ends in a zero or a five that's because
every red number is two more than a
multiple of five
and every blue number is three more than
a multiple of five
this means that when you add them
together you'll always get an
exact multiple of five and when you add
rolls that are multiples of five
the result will also be a multiple of
five
these sorts of relationships between
integers are studied in a branch of math
called
number theory here number theory shows
us that draco's score which is not a
multiple of five
cannot be achieved so he should be
disqualified as well
this leaves alexa whose score is a
multiple of 5
and is in the achievable range in fact
the most likely score is 400 so
she was a little bit unlucky but with
everyone else disqualified
she's the last heir standing all hail
queen
alexa the worthiest successor at least
if you agree that the best way to
organize your government is a roll of
the dice if you love mathematical
and logical problem solving we think
you'll also love
brilliant the courses in brilliance
website and app
take a fun hands-on approach to learning
like this challenge to drag the number
tiles
so that every row and column add up to
the target sums
it's not just a puzzle it also teaches
number theory
and logical thinking visit brilliant.org
ted ed to check it out plus the first
833 of you to visit
using that link will receive 20 off the
annual
premium subscription fee